I think one of the issues with these
sorts of non-fiction books is that it's
not really about what's true it is about
what's useful I think in a self-help
book like this James clear that you know
Atomic habits the four things that make
a habit stick it may not matter that
this mental model is 100 true yeah but
if it's a useful way of modeling the
information and it's true enough that
people can use it and apply it to their
lives you know similar to left brain
right brain analogy like that's not
actually how the brain works yeah I'm
like oh right brain is creative and left
brain is not but like just having that
model is still somewhat useful where you
think you know if someone says it
describes themselves as a more like
right brain kind of person like someone
says oh I'm really high on trait
extroversion like you know the ocean
personality traits it's not actually how
the brain works it's just a model that
we've taken to put on top of it to kind
of simplify things and as long as it's
useful it's all good